Finally,
yuns voted
against this amnesty bill.
Now this project
is returning to the justice committee
and they again have more time to continue
negotiating sessions that could be held by
to the separatists.
Here is the question I think we all ask ourselves
is as follows,
this is a posturing eh?
That I was
previously agreed so that the separatists,
so that yunts can follow you
bleeding at and getting more stuff out,
asking them for more regarding this amnesty,
or the situation is really un
and the PSOE is seeing the legislature shake,
because right now
what most media outlets carry
after this has been discovered,
is that the legislature eh?
Well eh,
their days are numbered.
I don't know.
How do you see it?
Well, look,
if you leave me I go for 1/3 option,
which is not posturing,
is an elector and I explain my approach.
Let's see,
the PSOE knows it is caught between two fires.
The first fire
is that of those who are burning him
its electoral base,
but they demand it and he will give it to them,
will end up giving him everything they are asking him to do,
because if not
knows he is being left hanging and needs the first
budgets.
That's why we are looking at the depth charge
and the acceleration we are seeing
because he needs to be able to endure a lot,
that I am convinced.
I also answer one of your first questions.
that it will last a long time,
but needs budgets to do so,
because otherwise it does not meet the demands of the first
adjustment that Brussels is making.
Let the first adjustment,
that no one thinks they are going to be on the right track,
is not going to be due to cost reduction,
is going through a brutal tax hike,
which is what they intend to put in.
But to get that support.
That's why it's accelerating the pressure.
Yuns yuns knows that this first measure is the important one.
He needs Jones' support,
of Esquerra and Bildu.
Let no one forget Bildu,
which is nowhere away,
a few months away,
very few months,
of those Basque elections,
which in addition
are going to be brought forward to April.
Well said that,
as everyone knows it is at stake in the first few years.
bars.
It has a first pressure fire
by the separatists,
that requires you to put in already
what I wouldn't want to put in yet
because he knows they will take him
in less than a year to the separatist referendum
and has to give
fits in with Brussels' demand for such an adjustment,
which requires budgets and
is going to take the first exam,
that are going to be
acceptance of preliminary rulings
before the eu court of justice,
of the judges
against the 4,000 people he intends to grant amnesty
for now,
for now 4000/1 because it is the ones,
I would like to highlight one thing here,
wildo already has
prepared a list of 4,000 people,
which he assures,
I repeat, the figure,
4,000 people.
We have published it in digital freedom,
who claims that they have received
torture by the police and the Guardia Civil.
You have to have a tough face.
But well,
there they go
and he knows he has all that pressure,
including that of how it goes head-on
against eu law
is going to have it very complicated,
if not absolutely impossible,
before the court of law
and if he likes the amnesty law,
which I also believe is what is going to happen,
because this is a legal aberration.
He has the problem of continuity of the legislature,
because the anger
from that moment on it will be brutal
of the partners who will not have paid
in Pedro Sanchez
everything you have been asked for,
which I repeat includes the separatist referendum
of rupture of Spain.
That's the triple track he's on,
with cymbals in their hands
Pedro Sanchez.
What happened?
You have summed up what has happened very well.
What has happened in these eh moments
is that they intended to put
pure darkness,
the pure way out of the criminalization of the penal code
for the purposes of yours,
of all possible causes of terrorism,
of all.
And beware,
a very important word
of a very important crime at this time,
nothing more and nothing less than the crime of treason.
Because there are reports from the European Parliament,
there are NATO positions demanded and agreed with the EU.
that talk about the fact that indeed
relations with Russia were an interference
foreigner.
And that appears in our penal code
in article 592.
And therefore it also affects European regulations,
because in fact they even have reports from March,
April,
May,
etc.
last year,
speaking directly
that there has to be a performance
against interference.
And they quote from Russia and quote in Moscow.
This appears in the documentation of the European Parliament.
If you go to the court of justice at the European Championship
having proposed an amnesty
for terrorist offenses,
breaking the unit required by the law of the union
of the concept of the crime of terrorism in the
27 Member States
and you come saying that you pass by the triumphal arch,
the latest reports that claim that indeed
there has been interference in by yuns
and you intend to stop a judicial process such as voliv,
where there are already
finding of meetings between Kremlin envoys
with yunts members,
because the game is over.
The court of law will return you.
But we go like some kind of fireball,
the amnesty law.
And in that dreadful,
horrible dish,
unconstitutional,
anti-Spanish,
anti-European,
anti-European law,
criminal anticode,
is in which the Socialist Party is involved.
And what is it that Yun scratched him?
You told him very well,
scratched him
time to go on
Pressing you
and has demonstrated to him that it is capable of hindering a standard for him
if not on close feet
with the text demanded by whom?
For which he was negotiating with Putin